what's the first writing exercise you
give to your students
they read the first three chapters of
the method writing book and they have to
write a journal entry in which they
write like they talk
how long is the journal entry
uh it could be 500 pages but for the
sake of the class
they can only read two pages
because otherwise they could be reading
100 pages and would be there all night
but i don't say you can't
you know
write as much as you want in your
journal for that day or that week but
for the class
limit it to about 500 words which is
about two pages so that we can respond
to it
which is 500 is a pretty good
normal chunk
but just a journal entry just write like
your doc
i i want to hear your voice if you're
not writing like a talk we will point
out those sentences where you had
he skillfully said you know adverbs
adjectives all that writerly stuff we'll
point it out and we'll we'll try to get
you not to do that
and
then in anticipation of the next chapter
we start identifying transformation
lines
and then the following week they have to
write a journal entry writing like you
talk but massaging a transformation line
and sorry the transformation line again
is
i was hiding the birthday cake
get rid of the birthday cake what's the
story of your life and the truth of who
you are i was hiding
i didn't want people to see me i was
afraid they wouldn't like me if they saw
who i was they would hate me
i'm not a good person
i'm a bad boy
well i was hiding ends up
because i remembered being locked in the
closet and i'm a bad boy that's just
that's the bottom story of my life
i'm hiding because i don't want people
to see me i don't want people to see me
because they'll know who i am if they
see who i am inside they know i'm a bad
person and then suddenly it came to me
i'm a bad boy
well that's a long way from i was hiding
i'm a bad boy and then from i'm a bad
boy
i'm stuck
which is where you ended up right so
that's i'm teaching them how to massage
a transformation line
then we do uh then we do the image
moment for two weeks because it's hard
and then we do something called dreaded
association which is another two weeks
again too complicated to go into now but
it was originally called the association
exercise and when i would assign it to
people and they would read it
they would get notes from their mother
as to why they were sick and couldn't
come to class
because they would dread it so
so then i
as a joke i called it the dreaded
association exercise
and that's what we call it and then of
course they do it and they bring it to
class and they're
they're just
shocked as hell how good it works and
what they can do with it and how it can
be a very creative thing and those are
the four concepts in the first level
right like you talk massage
transformation line image moment and the
dreaded association exercise
how many of your students are actually
able to write in a journal and not
censor themselves and not try to be too
writerly
eventually all of them
but in the beginning is that something
that a lot of them struggle with
many of them
don't have a problem with it they they
they haven't had enough experience
writing
that uh they know
how to be writers
the ones that have been writing a lot
and who think of themselves as writers
or i'm an actor
you know they might have a little
difficulty
or it might just be a sentence or two
here and there
and so we pointed out i talk about the
structure of the sentence and why that's
written and not spoken that if you were
talking you would have said it this way
or it would go this way or that word
would be there so we get into the
structure of the sentence and the
difference between speech and how we
write for instance um here's a sentence
that is
absolutely fine you'll see it in in
books all the time uh it begins with a
participle phrase standing by the window
i could see it was gonna rain nothing
wrong with that sentence great sentence
but we don't talk that way
we don't begin sentences with participle
phrases
we don't say
uh yeah i came home and standing by the
window i could see it was gonna rain
that's not how we structure a sentence
when we talk what we say is i was
standing by the window and i could see
it was going to rain or when i stood by
the window i could see it was going to
rain but never
standing by the window comma i could see
it was going to rain that's not how we
talk so we get into the structure of
sentences how it's not always a word
you know because everybody has different
vocabularies so it's not about that it's
about the structure of the sentence how
a sentence is structured and once you
start to hear
that the deep structure of speech as
opposed to the deep structure of a
literary construct it doesn't mean it's
bad writing it just means
you have to know the difference
then if you know the difference you can
choose when to do one and when to the
other so maybe at the worst uh a few
people will have one or two of those
sentences somewhere in what they write
and we deconstruct it and we talk about
it so basically i'm getting them to be
aware
of of their writing
that is speech-based now it's not always
going to be that level two goes into
those four tones that are not like you
talk so
we're writers and we can do that too but
first we want to like acting we want to
have a good foundation
so where you write like you talk
once in a while i'll get someone who's
been writing a long time
and they're really locked into their
style
and it's hard for them to shift out of
it
to because they think
they just think it's natural to throw in
those adverbs and adjectives and so
forth but
when you they're it's not good writing
sometimes
so sometimes even their writing writing
is not good writing
but most people take to it pretty well
why is it not good writing when when
someone's writing
to writerly to to using different terms
that we wouldn't use in normal
conversation uh if you've got a laptop
around
google stephen king
adverbs
he's got an essay on it
it's what amateurs do it's bad writing
so don't take my word for it
stephen king who's a good writer by the
way
excessive use of adverbs is the mark of
an amateur
um uh elmore leonard
he had an article in the new york times
review of books
um which was all about the 10 things
that bad writers do
the first one was excessive use of
adverbs
and often adjectives i mean you have to
have adjectives sometime but you got to
be careful
um
it was so
well received
that his publisher made it a book
now how do you make a book
out of one page article in the new york
times reviewer book books i'll tell you
you have illustrations on every page
you have type that's very big
and the paper is about as thick as a two
by four
and then you get a book
and it's sold really well
and number one is excessive use of
adverbs and adjectives so
you know this is not something that i
made up while i was living in a cave
every every professional writer will
tell you that you can you can spot an
amateur when they overuse
adverbs
and often
uh even the adjectives
so
who am i to argue with stephen king
and elmore leonard
it's bad writing
now there's other things that may not be
bad writing but it's not how you talk
so that's a different thing i want
people to know the difference so that
they can control
when they're writing what effect they're
going to create
he mumbled
he uh averred
he implied
he he shrugged
you know
uh i don't care if you live or die he
shrugged
so instead of saying
a word that has to do with uttering it's
it's a physical action i mean
writers do that bad writers do that all
the time and you know i feel like
sometimes i gotta go
quit it
so keep it simple
well that's a different issue oh okay
you can say complicated things but you
say it like you talk
i'm not saying you can't write
complicated sentences okay
okay it's just a question of is that
speech or is that a literary construct
that came when people started to write
the difference
one of the problems a lot of people have
with marcel proust
is his fancy
language
if you read him fast
you realize he's writing like he talks
there's a great deal of eloquence in
there but if you read it fast you
realize oh
he's talking
and the elegance that you think you're
seeing is often just long sentences
some sentences are half a page but he's
talking you had asked me about another
book
books i've read so another one that i
read during the pandemic where
it was on the libby app for the library
was my salinger year so it was about a
woman who worked at a publisher in i
think the 90s
and her job was to respond to jd
salinger fans and it's so great and they
made a film and it has um
uh margaret quality in it and uh right
sounds funny to see it yeah but but she
wanted to take care in responding to
these fans because they were so
emotional and they were so invested in
holden caulfield and she found that a
lot of them didn't want to hear what she
had to say they wanted to just have this
image of what
that character was and what the book
meant and she had to help them character
creates plot and voice creates character
salinger never wrote another book in
that voice
if you read franny and zoe and raise
high the roof beams carpenters it's a
completely different style and voice
if you read some of his short stories
like uncle wiggly in connecticut or the
laughing man
it's not holden caulfield at all it's
not that style that that was holden's
voice it's unique and it's what makes
his character so unique the voice
you get the voice you get the character
you get the character the plot will take
care of itself
yeah in fact they became very angry she
was trying to help them yeah and they
didn't want help they wanted to be angry
and they wanted to be with holden they
wanted to be with holden
yeah it was really fascinating book yeah
i'm looking forward to seeing the films
wait the challenger years yeah
no my salander year and it's based on
this woman in new york city in the 90s
yeah it's really no i don't think
they're ever going to make a movie of
catcher in the rye until
when his book goes in the public domain
or something because he won't allow that
he's dead now but i think he has
explicit instructions it's not to be
sold to the movies
yeah he had very rigid rules i believe
it sounds like he was a nice man the way
she described him in the book i don't
know his urban legend might have been
different but he
he treated her well and so she just had
very little interaction at the
publishing house right but it was
fascinating and
just you know those things are kind of
really not important whether the writer
is a nice man or not
writers can be
son of a you know
we may not realize it but it really
doesn't matter what matters is the world
they create
i don't care what salinger was like i
love holden
i love holden interesting and so he
created something that was real for me
and that's
that's all you can ask an author to do
a writer should reach the reader it's
not just about making themselves feel
good or looking good to their peers it's
about reaching the reader it's all of
that
i mean you do want to impress your peers
i mean we're human
we want other writers
you know our peers to appreciate what
we've done
obviously i want people to like my
poetry but it means a lot to me if
another poet who i admire really thinks
my poetry is good okay
um and i do want to reach my readers
but at the same time i want to satisfy
myself if if if what i did
a writer
sculpture painter
makes me happy and
i met the challenge then
i'll move on
at some point you can't really go by
what people think of your work you you
have to do it because it's your calling
it's what you have to do
but who wouldn't want someone to like
their work
but is there a certain point where
an author
an artist becomes so controversial
that it stops being about their work and
now it's just the legend of the artist
the mystique around them
the reputation whether it's true or not
okay and
if that's true what what are we gonna do
about that and that's what i'm asking
yeah what should someone do if their
their work is transcended to that point
what's
look
everything is going to happen under the
sun
you know
there's nothing i mean i i can't
pontificate and say well it should be
this way or it should be that way or it
shouldn't be this way it shouldn't be
that way
you know it's going to happen and
sometime it's out of the writer's
control things happen that they didn't
expect
or they didn't want and sometimes they
want that they they act a certain way
and it becomes a legend about how they
are and they cultivate that legend
you know i mean
writers are people
and you know people are crazy
not every crazy person writes a novel
but
some of us do
that's
it doesn't make a saying just because we
can write a novel